Samwell Tarly: According to legend, House
Targaryen survived the Doom of Valyria thanks
to Daenys the Dreamer, who foresaw the calamity
and convinced her father to flee their homeland.
It could be true. The Targaryens were always
a bit more.
Viserys Targaryen: This world wasn't always
so small and petty. Thousands of years ago,
while the rest of men prayed to gods, the
Valyrians became them.
Through magic or sheer will, they mastered
the greatest creatures in history. A horse
grants man dominion over the land, a ship
over the sea. But dragons gave us the sky,
and everything and everyone beneath it.
At its height, my ancestors ruled the Known
World. Whatever parts we didn't weren't worth
knowing. Our capital of Valyria shamed the
magnificent cities of the east, for hammers
and chisels were no match for dragonfire and
sorcery. It was a city and an empire built
to last until the end of time.
It didn't.
Four hundred years ago, the Doom fell on Valyria.
Mountains cracked open like eggs. Lakes and
rivers boiled. Fountains of fire, ash, and
smoke spewed from the ground, so high and
so hot that even dragons burned in flight.
The land splintered, and the angry sea rushed
in. In hours, the greatest city in history
became history.
But my ancestors didn't burn or drown with
the rest of their race. Twelve years before
the Doom, despite the sneers of his rivals,
Aenar Targaryen abandoned the capital with
his family.
Legends claim that his daughter foresaw the
destruction of the city in a dream. More likely,
Aenar met with some mishap at court and chose
exile over execution.
He and House Targaryen slinked away to a dreary,
remote, godforsaken island. Forsaken no longer.
With arts now lost to the world, we transformed
a tiny outpost into Dragonstone, a fortress
fit for the last Dragonlords.
Then Aenar's descendants settled into it like
a tomb for their lost homeland. Until Aegon.
When he looked east, he saw the past: old,
tired, dead. But when he looked west, he saw
the future: gold in the ground, gold in the
fields, and no dragons in the sky but his.
He and his sisters, Rhaenys and Visenya, flew
over the great continent, ostensibly visitors
to a strange land. But when Aegon returned,
he ordered construction of a massive table
carved in the shape of Westeros, with all
the notable rivers and mountains that they
had seen. A personal map of the Seven Kingdoms,
then ruled by seven squabbling families.
House Durrandon held the Stormlands from their
seat at Storm's End, due south of Dragonstone.
House Hoare of the Iron Islands had also conquered
and enslaved the Riverlands, and ruled them
from Harrenhal, a monstrous castle rising
on the shore of the Gods Eye.
House Stark held the frozen wasteland of the
North, the oldest, largest, and emptiest of
the kingdoms.
House Lannister held the Westerlands, the
wealthiest kingdom thanks to their gold mines.
House Gardener held the Reach, the second
wealthiest kingdom thanks to their crops.
House Arryn held the Vale, or rather the Vale
held them. The mountains were impassable except
through the Bloody Gate, which had never been
taken.
House Martell held the deserts of Dorne, probably
because no one else wanted them.
Together, the Seven Kingdoms made Westeros,
a realm that wasn't yet a realm, ruled by
great families who didn't know what greatness
was. Aegon would teach them.
Varys: Though House Durrandon titled themselves
"Storm Kings," they were little more than
gusts. Their kingdom in the Stormlands had
been doddering to its end for the past few
centuries, helped along by other houses. Most
of all by House Hoare, who were nearly finished
with a monstrous castle at Harrenhal, too
large and too costly a seat to rule only the
Riverlands.
King Argilac knew where the Ironborn would
soon turn. You'd think a king who wanted to
keep his crown would be wary of a man with
fire-breathing monsters, but King Argilac
Durrandon wasn't called "the Arrogant" for
nothing. Determined to arrest decline, he
sent an envoy to Dragonstone to enlist Aegon
Targaryen and his dragons against his enemies.
In exchange, Argilac offered lands he didn't
have, and a wife Aegon didn't need. For as
the Valyrians did, Aegon had wed his elder
sister Visenya. Then as the Valyrians didn't,
he took the younger Rhaenys as well. Two sisters,
two wives. Perhaps that's why he was so keen
to get off Dragonstone.
Aegon countered Argilac with courtesy. He
sent his own envoy requesting that Princess
Durrandon's hand be given instead to Aegon's
closest friend and rumored half-brother, Orys
been waiting for such a pretext? As his army
prepared to sail, ravens flew to every great
lord of the Seven Kingdoms. All bore the same
message: From this day forth, there would
be but one king in Westeros. Those who bent
the knee to Aegon of House Targaryen would
keep their lands and titles. Those who took
up arms against him would be thrown down,
humbled and destroyed. Poor old Argilac. He
couldn't even match Aegon in arrogance.
Aegon landed at the mouth of the Blackwater
River and raised a primitive Aegonfort in
the disputed lands between Harren's and Argilac's
kingdom so that neither could decide whose
problem he was. Adopting the customs of the
Seven Kingdoms, Aegon unfurled his own banner
with a red three-headed dragon breathing fire
upon a black field. Visenya crowned him with
a ruby-studded circlet of Valyrian steel while
Rhaenys hailed him as the first high king
the continent had seen since the Dawn Age.
As his lords and the gathered locals cheered
him, Aegon named his loyal friends to a Small
Council led by Orys Baratheon, whom he called
But for now, Aegon's kingdom contained only
a rocky island and a handful of fields. The
other kings had large armies, ships, castles,
and thousands of years of rule. But Aegon
had dragons. He had chosen for the words of
his house, "Fire and Blood." Before he was
done, the rivers, fields, and skies would
turn red.
Euron Greyjoy: Harren of House Hoare inherited
a kingdom that stretched from the Iron Islands
to the Trident. Too great a kingdom to rule
from a castle as shit as Pyke.
For forty years, his ironborn plundered the
Riverlands for stone, timber, and slaves to
build a seat worthy of him. Legend has it
that masons laid the final stone in Harrenhal
on the very day that Aegon landed in Westeros.
got there. They weren't the only ones. At
Aegon's approach, Harren's riverlords revolted,
led by House Tully.
I doubt Harren noticed.
Harrenhal could repel an army of a million
men. No ladder could summit its walls, and
shut his gates around himself, his sons and
his ironborn, and waited for Aegon's army
to drain back into the muck.
When Aegon finally saw the monstrous castle,
he asked for parley. Harren granted it. Valyria
had been the greatest empire the world had
ever seen. Harren wanted to piss on its ashes.
Viserys Targaryen: (as Aegon) "Yield now,
and you may remain Lord of the Iron Islands.
Yield now, and your sons will live to rule
after you. You see my army outside your walls.
You see my dragons."
Euron: (as Harren) "What is outside my walls
is of no concern. Those walls are strong and
thick."
Viserys: (as Aegon) "Dragons fly."
Euron: (as Harren) "But stone doesn't burn."
Viserys: (as Aegon) "When the sun sets, your
line shall end."
Euron: Harren spat and returned to his castle.
Once inside, he promised lands, riches, and
Tully's daughters to whoever could bring down
Aegon or his dragon. As the sun sank below
the horizon, all Harren's men patrolled the
battlements, hearing wings in every gust of
wind. But the moon rose and sank, and no dragon
appeared.
Viserys: While the ironborn were ringing the
battlements, Aegon drove his dragon Balerion
higher and higher in the night sky, so that
even the great castle of Harrenhal looked
like an anthill below them. Then they plunged
straight into the castle, well inside the
guarded walls.
The five towers of Harrenhal reached towards
Aegon like a hand. Balerion opened his mouth
and bathed all the fingers in flame.
Euron: Harren was right. Stone doesn't burn,
but men do, even when they're ironborn. The
dragon blasted my ancestors into ash that
choked the survivors when they screamed. Harren's
soldiers leapt from the battlements and died.
They huddled against the walls and died. They
fled across the yard and died.
Harren and his sons took shelter inside the
castle. The stone didn't burn, but as Balerion
blasted it with fire, it glowed white-hot.
The world's greatest castle became the world's
greatest oven, baking the last of House Hoare
within it.
Viserys: Outside the castle walls, the towers
of Harrenhal glowed red against the night
and began to twist and melt like five huge
candles, with liquid stone trickling down
their sides like wax.
The next morning, Aegon forged a new Riverlands.
He named the rebel Edmyn Tully as his Lord
Paramount of the Trident and had the other
riverlords swear him fealty as their new liege.
For centuries, House Hoare had terrorized
the Riverlands. Under House Tully, the Riverlands
would, at last, return to peace and prosperity.
After the castle cooled enough to allow men
inside, Aegon ventured into the ruin he had
made of Harrenhal.
He saw the ashen bodies, the scorched stone,
and the mangled and melted swords of his former
enemies. To his men's confusion, he ordered
these useless swords collected and sent to
his Aegonfort.
Varys: While Aegon marched on Harrenhal after
his coronation, Orys Baratheon had taken most
of his forces, and his queen Rhaenys with
her dragon, south to deal with the excuse
for the invasion: Argilac the Arrogant, King
of the Stormlands.
Argilac had his seat at Storm's End, a castle
considered the most impregnable in Westeros
after Harrenhal. Argilac may have been arrogant,
but he wasn't stupid or a coward. His lords
advised him to shut his gates and wait out
the siege, but he'd heard what had happened
at Harrenhal and refused to die a suckling
pig cooked in his own castle. He would meet
victory or defeat the same way, with sword
in hand. He called his banners and marched
to meet Orys Baratheon in the field.
Thanks to Rhaenys' dragon, Meraxes, Orys knew
Argilac was coming, how many men he had, and
how fast he marched. So Orys simply seized
the high ground and dug in on the hills to
wait for Argilac. As the two armies approached,
the wind rose to meet them, and the rain poured
from the sky, a gale which would give the
battle its name: the Last Storm. King Argilac's
lords urged him to wait for the weather to
die down, but the Storm King saw that the
rain was blowing into the faces of the Baratheon
men on their hills and Argilac outnumbered
the Baratheon host two to one, with four times
as many knights and heavy horse. Argilac attacked.
Three times Argilac led his knights against
the Baratheon line, but the hills were steep,
and the rain had beat the earth mud. The warhorses
foundered and slipped, and the chargers collapsed.
The battle seemed lost until Argilac ordered
the spearmen up the hill. Blinded by the rain,
the Baratheons didn't see them until it was
too late. One hill fell, then another and
another until only one remained in the Baratheon
center. If Argilac could break through there,
he could split the invading army and flank
both halves.
Argilac and his men charged, and the Baratheon
line broke, revealing Queen Rhaenys and Meraxes.
Argilac's vanguard burst into flame, and his
men panicked. The victory charge fell into
chaos, and Argilac himself was thrown from
his horse. But he didn't yield. When Orys
Baratheon arrived, he found the old king holding
off half-a-dozen men, another half-dozen dead
at his feet. Orys dismounted to meet the king
on equal footing and offered Argilac one final
chance to yield. Argilac cursed him instead.
As the storm raged around them, the grizzled
old warrior and the bearded upstart fought
for life and kingdom. In the end, Argilac
got his wish. He died, sword in hand.
As word of Argilac's death spread, his lords
and knights threw down their swords and fled.
Orys and his vanguard rode to Storm's End
to claim Argilac's castle for Aegon, only
to find the gates barred and the walls manned.
Argilac's daughter had assumed his crown,
and the new Storm Queen was as fond of yielding
as her father.
She declared that Orys would win only bones,
blood, and ashes here. But her men were weaker
than her, and that night Orys found Argilac's
daughter delivered, gagged, chained, and naked
to his camp. Argilac had refused to give Orys
her hand. Now, Orys could have any part of
her he wished. But Orys unchained the girl,
wrapped his cloak around her, and poured her
a glass of wine. He told her he would take
the arms, banner, and words of House Durrandon
to honor her father's courage in the Last
Storm. Conveniently, Orys had none of his
own to discard first.
The crowned stag became the sigil of House
Baratheon, and Storm's End their seat. Argilac's
daughter would even remain in her home, though,
as a lady instead of a princess. The Stormlands
were now Aegon's, and as tribute, Aegon demanded
the swords of the men Orys had defeated. For
what purpose, Orys didn't know.
Jaime Lannister: Aegon now ruled two of the
Seven Kingdoms, but he would no longer be
able to take the rest piecemeal. For the first
time in thousands of years, the kings put
aside their squabbles and joined forces against
a common enemy.
My ancestor, King Loren of House Lannister,
was head of the wealthiest family in the Seven
Kingdoms. When King Loren joined his forces
to Mern of House Gardener, King of the Reach,
they had the mightiest army in history, a
so-called iron fist to break the would-be
conqueror.
But while an iron fist can smash a man's face
in battle, you'd look silly hunting birds
or beasts with it, and Aegon had a creature
that was both.
The kings had never even seen a dragon, let
alone fought one. They had fought each other
for thousands of years, and victory always
went to the larger army.
Surely a force five times that of Aegon's
could manage one dragon. But Aegon arrived
with three.
Still, the Lannisters and Gardeners hoped
for victory. The battlefield they chose was
a wide plain with firm ground and clear skies.
Perfect for archers and mounted cavalry.
But neither of the kings spared a thought
for why the ground was firm. There had been
no rain for a fortnight, which meant all the
wheat and grass on it were bone-dry. Perfect
for dragons.
At first, the kings looked like they would
emerge victorious. When the horn blew for
battle, their armies swept around Aegon's
flanks, and their iron fist of mounted knights
smashed through his center before the dragons
could even enter the fray. But then Aegon
and his sisters took flight and unleashed
their dragons, not on the soldiers, but on
the dry fields all around them.
The iron fist unclenched and became a hand
outstretched for mercy. As Aegon promised,
he had none.
More than four thousand men died in the fires,
another thousand escaping them. Tens of thousands
returned home as monsters, burned and scarred
beyond recognition.
House Gardener never returned at all. The
Field of Fire, as the singers call it, claimed
the last of the Gardener line, and House Tyrell
rose in their stead as Lords of the Reach
and Wardens of the South.
As for my illustrious ancestor, when King
Loren saw the battle was lost, he rode through
a wall of flame and smoke to safety. Or at
least to a heroic capture a day later, where
he lay his sword before Aegon and knelt.
Aegon, true to his word, spared him and confirmed
House Lannister as Lords of Casterly Rock
and Wardens of the West. Why wouldn't he?
A Lannister always pays his debts, and now
we owed our lives to the crown. That was worth
centuries of subservience, at least. Besides,
Aegon had a fetish for collecting swords,
not heads.
He added Loren's to the pile his men had retrieved
from the Field of Fire and sent them back
to the Aegonfort.
Sansa Stark: With most of the South in Aegon's
hands, the best chance to throw back the Conqueror
now lay with the North, if we cared enough
to try.
Unlike our southern rivals, the Stark Kings
of Winter didn't forge the North into one
kingdom for glory or gold (there is little
of either here), but to survive.
Alone in Westeros, the North remembered when
worse than dragons lay waste to armies.
Thousands of years ago, the sun set on the
realms of men, and the Long Night began. A
new race emerged from the ice and snow: the
White Walkers. They demanded no crown, offered
no terms, spared no life, and the dead marched
with them.
With humanity facing extinction, a Stark sought
out the Children of the Forest, the most ancient
beings in Westeros, and convinced them to
ally with the men they'd once fought.
Together, the two races pushed the Walkers
back into the Land of Always Winter and sealed
it off from the Seven Kingdoms with the Wall,
three hundred miles of ice, stone, and earth
rising nearly seven hundred feet tall.
To guard it, they established the Night's
Watch, a brotherhood sworn to defend the living
from the dead, whose vows erase both titles
and crimes.
Viserys Targaryen: After the Long Night, the
North tried to forget it belonged to a continent.
Perhaps through pride, perhaps through sheer
ignorance. You never can tell with the North.
But as news of Aegon's dragons spread, Torrhen
Stark, the King of Winter, knew he couldn't
forget Westeros any longer and summoned his
lords to Winterfell. Many fools shrugged off
the threat while the rest placed wages on
how long the South would take to burn. Torrhen
silenced them with a command to assemble their
armies and descend from the North in force.
Sansa: As the kings of the Rock and the Reach
burned on the Field of Fire, the greatest
Northern force since the Long Night crossed
the Neck into the Riverlands.
But when King Torrhen arrived at the Trident,
he saw on the opposing riverbank the combined
strength of all Aegon's conquered kingdoms.
A force larger than Torrhen's own by half,
and with three dragons.
Viserys: That night, King Torrhen called a
conference of all his lords and advisors.
Some wanted to fight and trust Northern valor
to carry the day (and burn on the Trident).
The wisest of them wanted to withdraw to Moat
Cailin, the fortress which had thrown back
every southern invasion (and burn there).
One suicidal lord even wanted to ambush Aegon's
camp in the dark and kill the dragons as they
slept or at the very least, their riders.
Hard to tell what would have been his fate.
Burning? Beheading? Dismemberment? Perhaps
all three.
Sansa: My ancestor listened to their counsel,
and, in the morning, crossed the Trident under
a flag of parley.
Then King Torrhen of House Stark laid his
ancient crown at Aegon's feet and was named
Lord of Winterfell and Warden of the North.
Viserys: And the King Who Knelt.
Sansa: He had no choice, and thanks to him,
our soldiers returned to their homes whole
and unharmed. The swords that Aegon took from
them were not twisted, burnt, or mangled.
Viserys: Yet.
Petyr Baelish: The Vale of Arryn was the last
of the great kingdoms left. Old and proud,
House Arryn did what they always did in times
of strife: they shut the Bloody Gate, sealing
off the Vale.
Then, the Queen Regent Sharra of House Arryn
retreated with her son, the boy-king Ronnel,
into the Eyrie, their family's impregnable
fortress. From the top of their mountain,
they could look down on Westeros far below,
its problems hidden beneath the clouds.
But one day, Queen Sharra entered the outer
courtyard to find her young son sitting on
the knee of Visenya Targaryen and ogling her
dragon, Vhagar, beside her. Just as he asked
for another cake at dinner, little King Ronnel
asked his mother if he could ride on the nice
lady's dragon. Visenya smiled at Sharra. So,
Sharra imagined, did Vhagar.
Remembering her manners, Sharra asked if she
could have Visenya brought some wine or food,
she must be tired after such a long flight.
But Visenya demurred.
Bored with his mother's pleasantries, Ronnel
demanded an answer. Poor boy. He didn't even
understand the question. Sharra hesitated
for a moment, then asked Visenya, as a mother,
if it was safe for the boy. Visenya assured
her it was. What choice did Sharra have?
Whilst her son circled the castle, she collected
his little ringlet, her own regent's coronet,
and the ancient Falcon Crown of Mountain and
Vale, which the Arryns had worn for thousands
of years.
Ronnel had taken to the sky as a king, but
he landed as a lordling. Perhaps he considered
his ancient rights a fair trade for a few
minutes of flight, as a little boy would.
More likely, he didn't even notice the three
crowns at Visenya's feet or recognize the
swords of his garrison beside them.
Viserys Targaryen: The heads of Westeros had
bowed to Aegon, but its heart still beat free.
Oldtown, the center of the Faith of the Seven.
There dwelt the High Septon, the father of
the faithful, who commanded the obedience
of all Westeros, save the savages of the North
and their Old Gods.
When Aegon had landed in Westeros, the High
Septon had locked himself in the Starry Sept
and fasted for seven days and seven nights,
one for each of his gods. All he received
for his trouble was the divine wisdom that
if Oldtown took up arms against the dragon,
the city would burn, faithful and faithless
alike.
After the submission of House Stark, Aegon
marches towards Oldtown, steeling himself
for another battle. But he found the gates
open, with the High Septon welcoming him.
The pious fool even had the arrogance to grant
what Aegon had already won, and anointed the
last Valyrian as "Aegon of House Targaryen,
First of His Name, King of the Andals and
the First Men, Lord of the Seven Kingdoms
and Protector of the Realm." As if titles
meant anything to a man to whom time itself
now bowed. The Maesters would hence divide
all history into Before and After Conquest.
Most expected Aegon to stay and make Oldtown
his seat, but soon after his coronation, Aegon
returned to the mouth of the Blackwater River,
where he had first set foot on Westeros. A
small town had since sprouted around his primitive
fort. To honor their new master, the locals
dubbed it "King's Landing," though it looked
more fit for a hedge knight, with wooden palisades,
muddy streets, and piles of mangled swords
carted in from every corner of the conquest.
But when Aegon made it his court, wood became
stone, black mud was buried beneath a Red
Keep, and the collected swords of Aegon's
foes were blasted by dragon fire and became
a seat fit for the Conqueror and the greatest
dynasty this world has ever known. House Targaryen.
My family. My throne. Or so it should have
been.
Varys: But while Aegon titled himself Lord
of the Seven Kingdoms, in reality, he held
only six. The seventh, Dorne, had never knelt.
Visenya had flown into the Vale and returned
with its crown. Mimicking her sister, Rhaenys
had flown over the enemy force holding the
passes into Dorne and landed in the castle
of its ruling lady, Princess Meria of House
Martell.
Meria was eighty years old, fat, bald, and
blind. Behind her back, many sniggered at
her as the "Yellow Toad of Dorne." The beautiful
Rhaenys probably thought as much when they
met. She demanded Princess Meria kneel to
her brother Aegon, though she allowed that
on account of Meria's age and health, a simple
vow of submission would do.
But the princess told the queen that the Targaryens
weren't wanted in Dorne, and no Martell would
ever bow, bend or break no matter how badly
they burned. Rhaenys could have mounted her
dragon right then, and roasted Meria in the
castle as her brother had done at Harrenhal.
But whatever she saw in Meria's eyes scared
her right back to King's Landing, with a dragon's
tail between its legs.
After Aegon's coronation, Rhaenys returned
to Dorne with Aegon and Visenya and their
dragons. But no armies met them in the field,
and no lords defied them in their castles.
As the dragons approached, Dorne simply emptied.
House Martell had learned from Harrenhal and
the Field of Fire. The dragons were unbeatable
in battle, but wars were more than battles.
Unopposed, Aegon claimed Dorne for his own.
But as soon as he returned to King's Landing,
his castellans were hurled off towers, and
his royal garrison vanished in the desert,
never to be seen again. Except, perhaps, when
the winds change and the sands cough up old
bones and armor. Rhaenys returned on Meraxes,
intent on avenging herself against Meria Martell.
But Dorne was no longer empty. The Dornish
kept Meria's promise and fought even while
burning under dragon flame. And they won.
One day a bolt pierced the eye of Meraxes
and knocked the dragon out of the sky. House
Martell remained unbroken, unlike the unfortunate
Rhaenys. In their wrath, Aegon and Visenya
set flame to every castle and city but Sunspear,
trying to turn the people against House Martell.
But the Dornish stayed loyal, and when Aegon
returned to King's Landing, he found assassins
waiting for him in the streets of his own
capital.
If not for Visenya, the Conqueror would not
have enjoyed his conquest for very long. From
then on, the king and his family would be
guarded by the seven greatest knights in the
realm: the Kingsguard.
When Meria died in her sleep, a weak and tired
son sued for peace. But old Meria had exhausted
Aegon as well, and he granted the request.
The Targaryens still wanted Dorne, and eventually,
they would have it, but not at the point of
a sword. They would buy it the same way great
lords buy anything: with a daughter.
Viserys Targaryen: After the Conquest, when
men looked up, they saw dragons. Nobles learned
to keep their eyes down, but the gods weren't
used to sharing the heavens.
When Aegon died, the High Septon led the Faith
and its army in revolt, claiming that the
Valyrian tradition of wedding brother to sister
was an abomination in the eyes of the Seven.
Though no one could explain where the divine
Mother and Father had come from.
My ancestor Maegor the Wise, or Maegor the
Cruel as men slander him, put a bounty on
the head of every militant priest, and miraculously
the Faith soon returned to the septs.
With Dorne in the fold, and the Faith put
in its place, none in Westeros were left to
oppose my family, so we started opposing each
other.
In a Dance of Dragons, a Targaryen princess
tried to steal her brother's throne. Thanks
to her stupidity, most of our dragons died,
though one thankfully ate her before it did.
But even without our dragons, we were still
the blood of Old Valyria, which proved just
as dangerous.
and legitimized them all on his deathbed.
father's kingdom. And when they failed, their
sons tried. When their sons failed, their
grandsons tried.
Until finally, Ser Barristan the Bold, Knight
of the Kingsguard, slew Maelys the Monstrous
in the War of the Ninepenny Kings, ending
the last of the Blackfyre line.
Ultimately, without our dragons and with our
blood diluted by commoners, we failed to see
the greatest threat growing under our noses.